patty what's a world conflict you're
interested in
Oh Bob Armstrong where would patty be
without you well she probably wouldn't
be knee-deep in murder investigations
for starters you saw patty for who she
truly was a total beauty queen but
getting her to the top hasn't been easy
and now your hands are just as dirty as
Patty's are say what you want about
Netflix is insatiable but the people
have spoken
as they want another season we're about
to go through the good the bad and the
ugly of season one but stick around
until the end to find out everything
there is to know about insatiable season
two I might be skinny on the outside but
on the inside I'm still fatty patty
on July 19 2018 Netflix released the
first-ever trailer to its original
series insatiable and fans were outraged
before the series could premiere viewers
attacked Netflix integrity and a
petition banning the show from airing
began circulating the internet the
Netflix officials didn't budge on August
10th of that same year insatiable hit
the small screen people were outraged
the front woman Debbie Ryan received her
fair share of hate for being cast as the
leading lady the Netflix continued to
air the show and it became one of their
top 10 most streamed series of the year
it's easy to see UI viewers were
offended by the series as it plays with
very mature themes in the most
insensitive ways but in the end
insatiable is a satirical take on a
woman's journey to self-acceptance here
are some of season 1 biggest issues to
name a few I said skinny is magic
not skanky is magic you don't need to
shame Rabab the fat shaming if there's
one thing society is fighting for its
equality for all which is why many
people took offense in regards to
Patty's weight issues Debbie Ryan had to
wear a fat suit to shoot the first few
scenes of the series as well as any
flashback scenes and fans weren't having
it throughout season 1 had he talks
about skinny being magic being fat and
out of control
and being scared of becoming fat and
ugly again which isn't sending the best
message to children and teenagers
however while the show focuses on beauty
it does shine a light on how far people
will go to obtain unrealistic body image
goals
they don't understand you like I do
inappropriate relationships being a
young teenage girl with low self-esteem
can be disastrous which is why most
people try to approach this topic with
sensibility but insatiable takes things
to a whole new level there are a few
inappropriate relationships in season
one that led to the show receiving a lot
of hate for starters many viewers
thought it was super inappropriate for
Patti to have a major crush on Bob
Armstrong and to make things even worse
teenage brick ends up having a secret
relationship with Regina a woman more
than twice his age her assault jokes
another reason why the show received so
much backlash has everything to do with
Regina accusing Bob of assault and
molestation in the first-ever episode
Regina does this out of spite and ruins
Bob's reputation which angered a lot of
viewers due to the subject sensitive
matter many felt as though the issue
wasn't properly presented orientation
shaming Patty's best friend noni is
hinted toward having feelings for patty
however Nonis orientation quickly became
the butt of every joke to make matters
worse Patty's schoolmate Dixie stated
that being considered gay was worse than
being accused of cyberbullying all in
all the LGBT community did not like how
they were being represented on the show
I want you to hurt like I hurt revenge
but the problem didn't end there
fans couldn't believe their eyes and
ears when they found out the premise of
the show was getting revenge after
Patty's accident she sought revenge on
her classmates by showing off her new
body but when that wasn't enough
patty physically harmed those who fat
shamed her and went on to commit a
series of murders evidently there are a
lot of things wrong with season 1 of
insatiable
which is why bureaus are somewhat shots
that Netflix is coming out with its
second season on October 11th 2019
Netflix recently released the trailer
for season 2 and it's clear that things
are about to get hectic for patty Bob
and the entire show but what exactly can
we expect from the new season and will
Netflix be a little more sensitive this
time around well the short answer is No
things are only going to get worse from
here on out it's been confirmed that two
new actors will be joining the
productions after Vincent Rodriguez the
third who is best known for starring and
crazy ex-girlfriend will become a main
character in season 2 and fans predict
that he will pose as Patty's brand-new
love interests and then there's actor
Alex Landy from Grey's Anatomy who has
been cast in the reoccurring role
however little is known about his
character as of yet get excited now that
netflix has released the trailer for
season 2 it's clear that the season will
follow Patti as she tries to bury her
crimes and avoid prosecution at all
costs the season finale ended with Patti
killing Cristian and convincing Bob to
help her hide the body but not before
confessing to the murder of Stella Rose
it's easy to see that bob has his work
cut out for him in season two but will
paddy feel remorse for her actions and
try to come clean or will she go further
down the rabbit hole we're hoping that
Netflix has taking their viewers
complaints to heart and infuse their
scripts with more body positive messages
but we wouldn't bank on it because
despite the backlash they face
insatiable remains one of Netflix's most
watched series of 2018 tell us how you
feel about insatiable in the comments
below hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching we'll see
you next time
[Music]